foreign
yesterday a video went viral of a
Tick-Tock influencer describing her
encounter with a man on the Streets of
San Francisco and the video begins with
the classic line I'm literally shaking
right now and in your typical Tick Tock
video that opening would lead to a tale
of misgendering or some other
microaggression but in this case the
incident she describes assuming that it
happened as she describes
is actually quite serious listen
I'm literally shaking right now I was
just getting groceries and I live in San
Francisco and I never really feel fully
safe
in San Francisco
sure you know what I'm talking about and
I just got groceries I'm walking out of
the store and this guy is walking past
me and says move you stupid and he spits
in my face that's all over my face
then I say excuse me did you just spit
in my face and he says move or I'll rape
you there's also people everywhere and
everyone's just walking by because
they're like I can't handle something
else in San Francisco it's always
something else
I don't even know why I'm posting this
if you live in San Francisco
do you feel this way all the time I
don't feel safe ever I literally never
feels safe it's better when it's
daylight but night time no not leaving
my house
[Music]
now normally I would be highly skeptical
of a story like this but she lives in
San Francisco which makes it immensely
believable she lived in a normal
neighborhood it would be Unthinkable
that some man would just walk up to her
on the sidewalk spit in her face and
then threatened to rape her you know as
Jason Aldean would say try that in a
small town these things uh these kinds
of things don't happen in small towns or
even medium-sized towns yet in San
Francisco it has gotten to the point
where it would actually be a shock if
you lived there for a few months and
didn't get randomly accosted by a
lunatic on the street at least once
so although I don't I don't know what
really happened or if this really
happened at all I'm more than willing to
believe it because again this is San
Francisco
that's also why it is at this point very
hard for me to have sympathy for the
typical San Francisco resident who has
this kind of typical San Francisco
experience these are almost every case
liberals who vote for leftist candidates
who promise to make their communities
less safe
they vote for this they choose it they
literally ask for it
and then they get what they asked for
my capacity for pity has I confess
limits
and residents of San Francisco live
outside of those limits at this point
their communities do not have to be the
disgusting crime-infested wastelands
that they've become this is what the
people in those communities have chosen
it's what they've done to themselves and
continue to do
I made this point on Twitter and in
response to this video and I was
immediately scolded for saying this I
was told that my attitude is heartless
and callous and cruel and I'm not I'm
not going to succeed in persuading
anyone if this is how I approach the
issue
I was also lectured for uh making
assumptions about this woman just based
on the fact that she lives in the city
for all you know for all I know she
could be a young conservative white
woman in San Francisco
one of the like three in that category
in the city
yes possible technically
but in this case my intuition was
correct because here's another earlier
Tick Tock video from this same woman
watch
expression I'm very liberal and not very
religious so if you're going to be
offended maybe turn away now first Up
The Gift of Life sponsored by the right
to life I would give this a 6 out of ten
because the font choice is giving Disney
and it's just so predictable and to
someone who has given the gift of life
it's not that great and I want to return
it sometimes next up I give this one 9
out of ten because when was the last
time you honestly saw an entire
billboard dedicated to selling jacuzzis
and Spas so vintage and unproblematic so
I would give this one 4 out of 10
because I'm just not sure what is the
call to action here what do you want me
to do with this information sorry I
don't have an answer for that me neither
Alexa we're all a little bit confused
right now this next one I would rate
this 9 out of 10 because finally someone
understands that only big boys need
storage as a simple-minded weak little
female I absolutely do not need storage
I have no items and I don't own anything
especially land at least Indiana gets it
next up I will definitely offend someone
with this one do you know Jesus he died
for you well as one of the only Jewish
people in Indiana this weekend do you
know Jesus because he was my friend
first
four out of ten because who are you to
ask if I know Jesus
is very hard to judge because on one
hand the production value is very high
it reminds me when I walk by
anthropology and I see their new store
windows and I think wow whoever designed
that has such an eye for production
other hand though I look in this and
think Hmm pre-work vote for life but
what I really see is pray work though
for the fetus and then once the baby
comes out don't help those mothers don't
pay into taxes that support lunches and
health care and paid maternity and all
the things that mothers need to actually
care for their children especially women
of color who really have it way harder
than most women in this country so on
that hand I'm going to give this 0 out
of 10.
and then she walks outside of her house
and gets accosted by a random homeless
guy in San Francisco and I'm supposed to
feel
I'm supposed to cry about that
well you know they say you can't judge a
book by its cover but once again we find
that yes you can do precisely that most
of the time if you assumed that a young
white woman in San Francisco would be a
smug and sufferable leftist who makes
videos mocking Christians and pro-lifers
and people who live in small towns and
even joking about how she wishes she
aborted her own child which is what she
said there at the beginning if you
didn't catch it
well your assumption is as accurate as
was always destined to be
this is this is in other words exactly
the kind of person who has actively made
San Francisco into the toxic dump that
it is today
now she's crying about the consequences
of her own choices
has she learned her lesson though I mean
was this her Awakening moment am I
sitting here alienating someone who has
seen the error of her ways
no of course not of course not in fact
immediately after posting that video
where she's shaking in tears recounting
her traumatic experience her next move
was to post a series of follow-up videos
where she uses her experience as an
opportunity to lecture racist and
anti-semitic internet commenters who she
says have been making bigoted
assumptions
this is her priority after having just
been according to her assaulted and
threatened with rape by a guy on the
street
her priority after that experience is to
is to lecture people for being racist on
the internet
Grand Canyon University is an affordable
private Christian University that's
located in beautiful Phoenix Arizona has
a vibrant and expansive campus ranked
top 20 in the country according to
niche.com praise for its culture of
community giving and impact GCU
integrates the free market system and a
welcoming Christian worldview
Perspective into over a 320 academic
programs with more than 260 programs
online as of March 2023 earn your
bachelor's your Master's your doctoral
degree where you can engage with faculty
and connect with your own University
counselor who takes a personalized
approach for your success find your
purpose at Grand Canyon University
private Christian affordable visit
gcu.edu that's gcu.edu
here's one of her follow-up videos watch
ing very well groomed and well-dressed
white man also this is incredibly racist
and you will be blocked now goodbye
oh yeah sure A well-dressed white man we
know that those are you know those are
the kinds of people that are making our
cities unlivable gotta watch out for
those well-dressed white men
I mean every day we see another video of
well-dressed white men randomly
harassing and assaulting pedestrians
don't we It's Always A well-dressed
white man
the funny thing here is that if she just
said it was a white man we couldn't
believe it there are plenty of drugged
out white hobos in San Francisco and
every other City
but she had to throw in well-dressed and
well groomed because she didn't want
anyone to think that the person was
homeless after all homeless people are a
marginalized group they're victims
um and she couldn't allow her story to
be used to smear the good name of
homeless drug addicts
which raises the question who did
actually attack her did anyone attack
her who knows maybe it was A
well-dressed white man maybe it was a
maybe it was a white man in a
three-piece suit a top hat and a monocle
maybe the Monopoly man attacked her it's
possible strength strange things happen
especially in San Francisco but whatever
happened
we are left with this basic truth
every community
is the kind of community that it wants
to be
if the people of San Francisco actually
wanted to live in a safe clean City
where Law and Order Prevail if they if
they prioritized this if they prioritize
their own well-being
and the well-being of their families and
their children
then San Francisco would be safe and
clean and Law and Order would prevail it
really is that simple
now I'm accused of not reaching out not
trying to persuade people like the woman
in this video
and and that's true
um it's not my goal to persuade her
she's an adult she has a brain no matter
how it may seem she does have one she
understands at a basic level that crime
is bad
that it's bad to feel unsafe all the
time that garbage and fecal matter all
over the street that's bad
I don't need to persuade her of this
fact
even if I was interested in persuading
it which I'm not she already knows
she also knows that she's voting for
candidates who expressly promise to not
address any of these problems and who in
fact pledged to do everything they can
to make it worse
I don't need to explain that either
all these people already know that
they know what they're doing
they have decided to put their
ideological and political commitments
above their own safety in their own
Prosperity they have decided to
sacrifice everything on the altar of the
narrative again
I don't need to tell them this nobody
does they know it
what is left to do then but to leave
them to wallow in their own
self-inflicted misery it's not our job
to rescue them from the consequences of
their own actions and even if it was our
job there's no way we can it's not
possible
if there's any hope for these people now
it's going to come the hard way the
hardest way they're going to have to
make their own lives unbearably awful
they're going to have to suffer personal
tragedy they're going to have to really
experience the world that they've
created for themselves
that's what's going to have to happen
maybe they'll get to the point where
they can't take it anymore
well the reality is too dire to keep
ignoring
or maybe and I think that this is more
likely
they'll decide to go down with the ship
their cities will fall apart
and they will stay and let themselves be
buried under the rubble
maybe they'd rather die than admit that
they're wrong and that we're right
well so be it the choice is theirs I
can't make it for them
and yeah I don't feel sorry for them
but I will say that these leftists
who've ruined their own communities are
today canceled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there